[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with ian dunn
columnist at the i and katie balls
deputy political editor at the spectator
great to see both of you so to the front
pages then let us start with the metro
which has an image of prince charles
with the play on words wish you were
here or er
the sun front cover has a similar with i
hope i did you proud mummy
the guardian also has a picture of the
prince of wales with the headline tory's
bereft of ideas to tackle the cost of
living crisis
while the eye reports on the prime
minister making a u-turn on the cost of
living crisis
the daily express has the same story
saying boris johnson promises firepower
to help hard-hit families
the daily mail references the queen's
speech and the new law to make work from
home easier
axed from the queen's speech
the times picks up on the proposal to
allow councils to tax the profits of
developers
the delhi telegraph reports that liz
truss is standing firm in the face of an
eu trade war threat
and the financial times reports that
elon musk has pledged to reverse
twitter's morally wrong ban on trump
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages while you watch us so let's return
then to our guests ian dunt and katie
balls who are here with us and we kick
off obviously with the queen speech um
and the criticism uh ian of the
government over what is or is not in it
on the cost of living crisis
yeah of the fact that there's nothing in
the queen's speech i mean it's been what
six weeks since we had the spring
statement from rishi sunak comes out
basically offers absolutely nothing to
people who are struggling for some
inexplicable reason the government has
spent the last six weeks doing
absolutely nothing about that situation
while getting pounded electorally for
their failure to do so they come out
with a set of bills today
i mean there's just nothing there it's
like an election leaflet masquerading as
a government they have no plans really
of any sort of
meaty substantial thoughts for any
subject other than the fact that they
want to further imprison protesters and
other effort from pretty patel in the
home office when it comes to actually
improving people's lives it is just an
utter black hole the only detail of
which was boris johnson saying oh maybe
in a few days i'll come up with
something which the treasury later very
quickly said well actually probably he
won't
do you agree katie um the prime minister
did say obviously they need to be
responsible with cash the idea of course
is to eventually cut taxes ahead of a
general election the hint from rishi
soon act that the help might come in the
autumn so so where do you see um the
cost of living crisis sitting in the
legislative program in the uh in the
parliamentary term ahead
well i think the issue and this is why
in a way
the decision to lead the queen's speech
by saying that the cost of living crisis
was obviously the government's priority
as was growing their economy and that's
all very well but it didn't really
correlate to the contents of the queen's
speech and that is down to a few reasons
one of them is lots of the really big
issues facing the economy and you're not
going to answer with legislation and
instead you're looking for
you know whether there's going to be an
early budget something which um an
emergency budget something which
treasury have ruled out we'll be looking
more to measures like that the most we
got was um
uh the words saying that the government
was going to work closely with the bank
of england to try and bring down
inflation now that would imply that
actually the government does not plan to
spend much or throw more funds at this
particularly because we know that
ministers are concerned about
actually making the issue of inflation
worsely into stagflation
i think therefore though by putting this
focus on it today when really if you
look at the bills in the in the queen's
speech there are more on things like
security policing channel four much
wider and it is just led to a situation
where everyone said well you've just
said it's about cost of living what have
you got to show for that and then as
we've just been touched on there was the
confusion when boris johnson appeared to
say something will be you know more will
be said in a few days and actually not
just the treasury but it feels as though
because in downing street too there's a
general sense that oh no don't don't
overread this and so it was it was a
strange type of affairs but i think the
fact the prime minister felt the need to
say that does suggest he is feeling the
pressure
yes the daily express uh quoting that uh
fiscal firepower uh would be used to
help the hard hit families um but boris
johnson did you know it did say that the
legislative program would build the
foundations for decades of prosperity
but that's years ahead isn't it it's the
short term issues right now that that
people uh really need that's uh the
daily express meanwhile um ian the daily
mail focusing on working from home a new
law to make working from home easier was
axed from the queen's speech tell us
more about this
yes the employment bill um it's not just
that you know also it would have created
a watchdog to fight for workers rights
sort of a product of the conservative
party at a rather different ideological
stage not very long ago just months ago
after the election when it was suddenly
you know thinking about the red wall
thinking right we'll fight for workers
we're a much more kind of you know
stealing labour's clothes not really
like the thatcherite party that it seems
to be much more comfortable posturing as
at the moment so yes that has lost me i
haven't got any sign of that bill yes
working from home seems to be in the
spotlight the sort of jacob reese mobs
attack on the civil service are an
indication of that there's no sign
whatsoever that there's been any thought
as to why this might be the case except
for just the sort of instinctive
knee-jerk prejudice against change
people had found during the pandemic in
an atrocious few years one of the only
good things that came out of it for yes
lucky office workers for white collar
workers was that they found more of a
balance in their working life and yet
they could be in sometimes and they
could be in the office sometimes and
maybe things would work out in a more
uh satisfying way in terms of the whole
of your life taken as a whole that of
course is now something that the
government seems keen to dismantle or at
least fail to support they're completely
unable to express any economic or moral
or social reasons for why that might be
the case yeah it reminds me of the the
lord sugar versus pwc battle uh pwc
who've given their staff friday
afternoons off during these summer
months and that was roundly criticized
by lord sugar and people say that's a
part of the culture war of the future of
employment do they not in the meantime
the sun uh has that um slightly mournful
looking photograph there of prince
charles um it's elsewhere in the papers
as well uh one paper describing that he
was looking over to the uh to the crown
of his missing mother effectively but i
hope i did you proud mummy that you know
that the main news of today was the
absence of her majesty the queen and
really many people feeling that we'll
never see her do this occasion again
katie
yes and i think as as you say and as the
paper notes there i mean the sun has
prince charles looks emotional yesterday
as he stepped in for his mother and
obviously at the state opening of
parliament and i think that while we all
expect at some point to see british
child taking on these roles it clearly
is tinged with sadness in the sense it
suggests that all is not well with the
queen i think that the palace is very
keen to insist um not to overread into
this saying that she watched it from
home and i think the question is is the
queen going to be able to take part in
all the queen jubilee set the uh jubilee
celebrations um that are being planned
um i think if if it is obviously giving
someone rest uh given their age and so
they can do that then i think everyone
will be pleased that that is made
possible but it obviously does add to um
general concerns
and the the matte cartoon uh ian perhaps
you could talk us through that um it is
looks like a footman with a crown
uh and state crown delivery notes if the
monarch is not in parliament leave in
porch try neighbors leave by throne and
that is indeed what happened
yeah we've got this extraordinary site
of the sort of special crown car which
the the which it sort of went off in
towards the end it's not something that
i'd ever seen before and was of course
pretty much on course for the sort of
absurdity of britain's ceremonial uh
life we it does feel a bit like we're
getting prepped i mean there may be
medical reasons for it too but it does
feel a bit like we're getting prepped
for the idea of charles as king which
you know is going to happen and probably
it's going to happen quite soon and it's
not such a bad thing as it is the
british people have a sort of aversion
to charles or it's quite fashionable to
dislike him there's nothing there to
dislike at all he's
sort of generally sensible and will be
able to hold it relatively well and i
think that this initial sort of surprise
of getting used to it something that
we're going to have to go through at
some point and it might as well be now
yes in the appearance too of uh prince
william uh many people suggesting this
is a reminder that the monarchy is not
an individual it is an institution and
that helped reinforce that certainly
well plenty more coming up next we will
have the latest on the foreign
secretary's trust standing firm we are
told in the face of an eu trade war
threat that on the front of the
telegraph discussing that in just
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me once again ian dunn columnist at the
eye and katie balls deputy political
editor at the spectator uh to the
telegraph we go now katie and uh what to
do about that border in the irish sea uh
list trust we're told is standing firm
with the prospect of an eu trade war uh
what happens next
yes and this is interesting because um
there was not a specific protocol bill
in the queen's speech but there was a
reference to
and the arrangements of belfast
agreement protecting it
and behind the scenes there is a
situation where
there's trust the government could bring
forward legislation on this uh what this
story is talking about is unilaterally
um changing the northern ireland
protocol so that is not technically
triggering article 16 which is the way
which you um you know you start you you
suspend it this is about actually just
changing bits to it and then seeing what
the eu does in response
and i think it doesn't take a great mind
reader to predict that the eu would not
be particularly happy and so the
question is how far does the foreign
secretary want to go does she have the
backing of the prime minister and the
rest of the cabinet and if so what were
the response of the eu be i think there
is some division in cabinet because you
have figures such as michael gove also
rishi you know you have been concerned
about um going uh going for something
quite robust in terms of uh you know
actually acting on the protocol if that
is going to lead to the eu retaliating
potentially ripping up the trade deal
completely and before you know it ending
up in a trade war between the uk and the
eu now this is potentially the worst
case scenario but it's possible
and if you had that time when there was
a cost of living crisis you can imagine
how much worse and how sensitive
actually the economy would be to this i
think that the the counter argument and
what you'll hear from those pushing for
changes is they spent so long trying to
get changes to this agreement something
the uk did agree to initially um that
they're getting exasperated with the eu
and but i think what the story is saying
is i mean one last attempt between the
uk and eu to see if they can find some
common ground judging it by previous
attempts i i wouldn't get anyone's hopes
up yes i mean this is your specialist
area of course ian is it not um
the point i suppose is will the eu be
softened at all that this does appear
now to be holding back the political
process in northern ireland will that
make any difference at all or is this
just a point of principle almost for
both sides now
well i just don't get that i mean the eu
already made concessions they made
extensive concessions last year really
big ones at the time everyone was really
quite surprised that they would go that
far getting rid of loads of checks for
goods really big concessions on
agriculture on medicines apparently
everyone's forgotten that this ever took
place it certainly made no difference to
the belligerence of the british
government which you know if you feel
like you're experiencing groundhog day
it's because basically you are because
every two weeks has to be a story about
how the british government's going to
detonate the protocol or trigger article
16 or something or other i mean it's not
as if they haven't made efforts to help
the uk soften the deal that it itself
proposed and then signed and now wants
to detonate it's completely insane state
of affairs so i wouldn't blame the eu
thinking that they're negotiating with a
mad dog
how britain thinks that like now would
be the time to do it to put itself not
just into a pitched battle with the eu
but into a pitch battle with washington
as well which has made very clear the
way that it will feel if we just start
unilaterally ripping national agreements
we've come to is another matter
we're running out of time what a shame
ian done katie balls lovely to see both
thank you both very much indeed